a few months ago
my daughter asked me a very simple
question
who are your heroes dad
i said well besides my father
hoping she would get the hint
one of my big heroes is malcolm mclean
i realized that malcolm mclean is not
really known on social media today
but in 1955
mclean invented a metal box that changed
the world
the shipping container
that invention
reduced the cost
of shipping cargo by more than 90
percent
and as a consequence
global trade increased 200 times and
lifted hundreds of millions of people
out of poverty by connecting them and
their goods to global markets at very
very low costs
i'm sure mclean's invention started with
a big dream to transform the
transportation industry
and i know it took a lot of attention to
details
to change all of the equipment of all of
the transportation companies worldwide
to benefit from this container
to me
that is what leadership is all about
dreams that inspire people to pursue
opportunities that may seem impossible
and details
because without attention to the details
the dream will just stay a dream
mclean's dream was to transform
the cargo transportation industry by
making it affordable
it is time to transform it again
we urgently need to make it sustainable
more than nine percent of co2 emissions
globally come from transporting goods
around the world
so what is the dream
in 2018 the management team of ap miller
mask
the global shipping company i lead as a
chairman
made a commitment to make the company
carbon neutral by 2050.
for some people 2050 sounded like a long
time into the future but in fact this
was a very ambitious dream for a
shipping company
to be carbon neutral by 2050 we needed
to invent a zero carbon container vessel
by 2030
because then it would take roughly 20
years to replace all of the 750 vessels
that we operate
so the dream was truly big
and really inspiring
but to be honest
in 2018
we did not know how to do this
we had to work hard on the details
now at that time we had already focused
a lot of attention
on reducing co2 emissions from shipping
in fact we had achieved more than 40
reduction per container moved since
2008.
that was done by building bigger and
more efficient vessels
and by slow steaming
which means
sailing the vessel slower so it consumes
less fuel
but we were reaching the limit
obviously you could sail so slow that
you don't sail at all and you would save
all of the co2 emissions
but that didn't seem like a good
solution
now some of the
first humans who sailed the big oceans
the people from polynesia
had figured out zero carbon shipping by
using sales and it is true that sales
can reduce the fuel consumption somewhat
but it cannot deliver on the efficiency
and accuracy needed in today's global
supply chains
another alternative is batteries
but for the large vessels sailing the
big oceans
the batteries would take up 60 percent
of the capacity of the vessel
some shipping companies started ordering
vessels based on lng liquid natural gas
lng
is a fossil fuel it will never lead to
zero carbon shipping slow steaming sales
batteries lng
none of it would make us
be carbon neutral so what else
well
we knew we had to look for other
solutions
and we realized we couldn't do it alone
to help us find a solution our main
shareholder the ap miller foundation
donated 400 million danish kroner to
create a global center for zero carbon
shipping
in copenhagen
that center would bring together
companies and specialists from all over
the world
not just from the transportation
industry but also from energy from
chemicals and engineering
and now
less than three years after our big
dream
we have found a solution
it is called power2x
now power2x is not a new technology nor
did we invent it it is a combination of
known chemical processes to convert
green electricity
to a green fuel
first you convert the green electricity
from solar or wind to green hydrogen
that is done through electrolysis
and then the green hydrogen can be
converted to various types of green
fuels through chemical processes
the benefit of power 2x is that it
produces a green fuel that is liquid at
normal temperature and can be used in a
combustion engine
so instead of spending 20 years to
replace all of our 750 vessels
and create a big pile of waste
we believe we can retrofit existing
vessels by adding a combustion engine
designed for green fuel
and with that achieve zero carbon
shipping much much earlier
on top of that power2x is actually a
very nice solution for one of the
biggest problems in renewable energy
systems the storage problem
when there's too much wind and sun
you can convert the unused electricity
to a liquid green fuel that can be used
in many different industries
so
what are the challenges
well
i often hear the same concern when it
comes to sustainability
can we afford it
and yes it is true that this green fuel
is more expensive than the bunker fuel
we use today in fact it is two to three
times more expensive with current
technology
like always
we need to scale these solutions to get
the cost down
but even if the green fuel would be two
times more expensive than the bunker
fuel
it should not be a show stopper come on
even at that price
a pair of sneakers
transported from asia to the us or
europe
would only cost five cents more
so for me
the argument around affordability is
just a bad excuse for not making the
necessary decisions and investments
and if we had a price on co2
let's say around 150
the affordability argument would
disappear
i urge governments to show leadership
and implement a global price on co2 now
because with that
we could focus all of our attention
on the real issue which is not the price
but the scale
at mask i asked this following question
how much green electricity do we need to
fuel all of our 750 vessels with green
fuel
our fleet today consumes 10 million tons
of bunker oil
to replace that with green fuel
we estimate that we need 220 000
gigawatt hours of green electricity
that
is the equivalent of 10 percent of the
installed base of solar and wind in 2019
and mask is 20 percent of the cargo
shipping industry so to fuel the cargo
shipping industry alone
would consume 50 percent of the entire
installed base of green electricity
and that's just cargo
shipping
in other words we need a dramatic
exponential scale of installations of
solar of wind of hydrogen production of
green fuel production to solve this
problem
we estimate that the total investment
will be in the neighborhood of two
trillion dollars which granted is a lot
of money
but actually
it is the equivalent of four years of
capital expenditure in the oil and gas
industry today
i predict
that for the next 10 years
the demand for green fuel will be
significantly higher
than the supply
isn't that wonderful
higher demand and supply normally means
great business opportunities for
everyone who choose to participate
and it proves one of my key assumptions
in today's world it has become good
business to invest in sustainable
solutions
my conclusion is very simple
we have the technologies needed to
create a sustainable future what we need
is leadership
leadership to get us there faster
on the first of july 2021
mask ordered the first vessel designed
for green fuel
it will be delivered in 2023.
only two months later we ordered another
eight large vessels and made our first
investments in green fuel production
what seemed to be an impossible dream
only three years ago is becoming reality
now
seven years ahead of the original plan
this is a leadership moment
it is time for us to pursue big dreams
even if they seem impossible
and it is time for us to collaborate
around the critical details so we get to
a sustainable future much
much faster thank you very much